mon cher ami je veux remercier en votre
nom à tous pour l'excellence de leur
travail
guillaume larrivé françois noël buffet
et roger karoutchi avec eric woerth
ils ont fait un travail remarquable
isabelle naturellement mais même dans
des conditions dont il faut bien noter
qu'elle était particulièrement difficile
je voudrais leur témoigner de notre
reconnaissance
quand j'ai voulu organiser cette journée
j'ai été immédiatement accusé de
droitiser de suivre jones et qui par la
gauche est normale mais même par une
partie des motos est ce qu'on peut
comprendre que la vocation d'un grand
parti politique comme le nôtre c'est de
parler des sujets qui préoccupent les
français et non pas des sujets qui
préoccupent les élites et le nombriliste
français je me souviens des adresses qui
m'était destinée tu vas donner une
mauvaise image
le seul endroit
on ne devrait pas parler d'immigration
c'est donc chez les républicains
parce que pour moi le problème c'est que
nous apportions des solutions pour le
des français et non pas que nous
regardions dans un grand miroir je veux
dire d'ailleurs que à propos de cette
question de l'immigration c'est toute
latitude scherick de notre formation
politique à l'endroit des défis français
qui se posent
question n'est pas de savoir où nous
nous trouvons sur la géographie
politique mais la façon nous sommes
décidés à affronter les problèmes de la
france avec lucidité avec sérieux la
première chose à dire c'est que la
france a le droit d'accueillir sur son
territoire qui est choisi d'accueillir
sur son territoire est la france cher
pierre encrevé reciente des aigris a le
droit de refuser sur son territoire qui
elle choisi de refuser sur son
territoire si on n'est pas d'accord là
dessus c'est pas la peine de chercher
autre chose
c'est la base c'est le point central la
liberté de circulation nous avons voulu
en europe pour les européens ne vont pas
dire que dans notre esprit a plus de
frontières cela veut dire que les
frontières qui sont les nôtres nous
choisissons de les abaisser
pour ceux que nous avons décidé de
recevoir et nous choisissons des
maintenir pour ce que nous n'avons pas
décidé de recevoir la libre circulation
des européens en europe est une chose
qui ne veut pas dire la libre
circulation des non-européens en europe
en tout cas tant qu'il n'y a pas une
politique migratoire commune en europe
et finalement sur cette affaire
d'immigration
ce débat est cloisonné ans fermé
cadenassé d'abord par le conformisme la
maladie française du conformisme mon
dieu comme il est confortable de répéter
des slogans
mon coeur bat à gauche connaissez vous
beaucoup de vos relations qu en choeur à
droite
quelle originalité débat cadenassé par
l'immobilisme français de ceux qui se
complaisent dans des postures
prétendument morale qui ne sont que des
impostures idéologique s'abriter
derrière la morale pour masquer une
imposture et je veux dénoncer la
description qui est fait de notre pays
et de nos compatriotes qui serait
égoïste
il n'y a pas un continent au monde plus
ouvert que l'europe
la culpabilisation des européens et des
français est à proprement parler
insupportable par rapport à ce qui se
passe dans le monde entier et enfin
c'est un débat verrouillé par le
juridisme comme il est commode
d'abdiquer devant le juridisme quand on
a abdiqué devant toute volonté politique
l'absence de volonté politique se
traduit par la démission devant le
juridisme alors il nous faut revenir sur
cette crise
cette crise ajoute un problème un drame
structurelles ce drame
il porte un nom c'est le déséquilibre
démographique
si on refuse de voir que le premier
problème de l'humanité jeudi de
l'humanité c'est l'absence de toute
politique de natalité sur la surface de
la planète alors que nous sommes 7
milliards et que dans trente ans nous
serons 9 milliards si on refuse de voir
que la question de la maîtrise de la
natalité sur notre planète
combien d'habitants peuvent-ils vivre et
quelle est l'évolution des prochaines
années je ne reviendrai pas sur l'époque
de la grotte de lascaux il y avait dix
mille européen
enfin l'europe était d'un vague projet à
l'époque ils étaient dix mille somme 500
millions d'ici à trente ans l'afrique
devra nourrir forme et l'eau j'ai
employé un milliard de nouveaux
habitants on peut refuser de voir ce
chiffre
dans ce cas là c'est pas la peine de
faire un débat sur l'immigration et
cette population est la plus jeune du
monde
50 % des africains aux moins de 25 ans
voilà les données du problème de 1950 à
2050 la population d'afrique
subsaharienne passera de 180 millions à
1 milliard 800 millions d'habitants
pardon le défi c'est bien sûr celui des
réfugiés de guerre de série mais
indépendamment de la situation syrienne
nous avons une question massive la
méditerranée 800 km de large
c'est pas l'atlantique c'est pas le
pacifique et par le détroit de gibraltar
il ya 12 km entre l'europe et l'afrique
on peut dire que ça ne nous concerne pas
alors dans ce cas là on se présente on
se prépare des catastrophes et c'est pas
une question d'image c'est pas une
question de générosité
c'est simplement une question de
lucidité il y a ceux qui seront à la
hauteur de la situation
en élevant le débat en regardant la
situation face et à ceux qui
démissionneront par lâcheté alors
naturellement il ya le défi immédiat
mais cher pierre des désordres du
moyen-orient sur cette question comme
sur tant d'autres je dirai au pouvoir en
place qui a quelque chose d'effrayant
pour nos compatriotes
on a le sentiment qui est en train de se
transformer en certitude que le pouvoir
en place a perdu toute maîtrise des
événements ne contrôle plus rien
que nous sommes dans une pente glissante
ça va de plus en plus vite plus personne
ne contrôle un jour on est pour les
quotas le lendemain on est contre le
surlendemain nouveau pour plus personne
ne comprend rien y at il un pilote
la réponse est non ce qui est embêtant
c'est que nous sommes dans la voiture
alors face à cela il faut d'abord
dénoncé les mensonges
monsieur hollande s'est engagé à
accueillir 24 mille réfugiés
c'est faux il s'est engagé à accueillir
20 % du flux européens
je vous le dis ce n'est pas une question
d'obsession contre qui que ce soit le
chiffre de 24 mille il faut et si nous
voulons recréer les conditions de la
confiance entre nos compatriotes et la
parole publique
mieux vaut dire la vérité le chiffre de
24 mille c'est faux je ne pense pas que
ce sont les 1000 euros versés par le
gouvernement aux communes par places
d'hébergement supplémentaires qui va
changer la donne
j'ajoute que les quotas ne peuvent être
la conséquence ne peuvent être acceptés
tant qu'il n'y a pas une politique
d'immigration commune
moi je suis tout à fait prêt à ce qu'on
parle des quotas comme conséquence d'une
nouvelle politique d'immigration
pas avant parce que si on accepte les
quotas maintenant cela veut dire qu'on
accepte des gens sur des critères qui ne
sont pas du nôtre puisque naturellement
une fois rentrés dans l'espace de
schengen ceux qui sont rentrés par un
pays vont se précipiter chez nous
puisque nos allocations sociales sur
plus important que chez nos voisins
dire cela c'est bien insulté personne
c'est dire aux français voilà la
situation devant laquelle nous nous
trouvons qu'est ce que ça veut dire
bâtir une nouvelle politique
d'immigration
il est devenu évident même pour les plus
aveugles que le système de schengen ne
fonctionne plus
peut-être vous souvenez-vous que dans la
campagne de 2012
j'avais fait scandale il faut dire qu'il
y en a qui mettent le scandale
rapidement oui parce que pour moi le
scandale c'est tout ce qu'on voit c'est
parce que j'ai dit j'avais dit à
l'époque président de la république que
la france sortir est de schengen avant
un an
si schengen n'était pas modifié je me
suis fait attaquer à l'époque par tout
le monde y compris dans ma propre
famille il a fallu donner des selles
comme si le problème était ce que je
disais alors que le problème c'est la
réalité
schengen ne fonctionne plus alors
maintenant si même des gens de gauche le
il y en a un que je veux absolument
remercier parce qu'elle a pris un risque
énorme ya un ministre qui a osé dire
quelque chose de très choquant personnes
sensibles quitter la salle monsieur le
guen a dit sarkozy n'a pas forcément
tort
je vous remercie pour la gravité du
propos devant une crise de cette nature
un homme comme pierre joxe qui n'est pas
à proprement parler un compagnon de
route des à l'époque de mitterrand
nous avons fait une erreur schengen
avait un péché de naissance l'absence
d'une politique d'immigration commune et
j'ai appelé dès le début de cette crise
mais c'est pas pour dire j'avais raison
c'est pour vous compreniez qu'il ya des
solutions on peut s'en sortir
j'avais appelé à suspendre la libre
circulation des ressortissants non
européens au sein de schengen
immédiatement l'amoureux fou des micros
monsieur basse s'est précipité pour
faire rempart de ses convictions en
disant c'est pas possible
le pauvre huit jours après les deux
tiers des pays européens faisais ce que
je demandais et que le gouvernement
français refusaient et c'est pour ça que
je vous dis le perdons pas trop de temps
à critiquer madame merkel j'ai pas
l'intention de critiquer madame merkel
le jour où elle fait en allemagne
ce que je demande que l'on fuit en
france
s'il fallait la critique et c'est pas
maintenant on m'a dit que c'était
impossible
j'ai même vu l'ineffable monsieur bayrou
dire qu'il peut imaginer qu'on empêche
des douaniers et qu'on établit ses
frontières si lui il imagine pas
c'est plutôt bon signe quant à nous
ayant dirigé les douaniers je sais qu'il
y en a un peu moins de 30000 et qui a
même cher bruno une police de l'air et
des frontières
il doit pas être très difficile de dire
à la police des frontières de rétablir
des contrôles aux frontières pour les
ressortissants non européens
quant aux frontières mon cher henri
guaino dont nous avions si bien parlé
je n'ai pas vu un traité international
indiquant qu'elle n'existait plus et
contrairement à ce que disent ceux qui
ne réfléchissent pas assez profondément
les frontières sont un élément de la
stabilité
quand il ya des frontières celui qui
vient d'ailleurs et reçu en ami qu'il
n'y a pas de frontières celui qui vient
d'ailleurs est reçu comme une menace
mais je pense exactement la même chose
pour la khl de propriété ou pour le bail
d'un locataire quand on est sûr de son
titre de propriété ou de son droit à
être locataire on reçoit celui qui est
bien l'extérieur comme un ami quand il
n'y a pas de titre de propriété
quand il n'y a pas de frontières celui
qui vient de l'extérieur est une menace
la frontière est un élément de stabilité
pour le monde
d'ailleurs les parties du monde où il ya
de moins de stabilité sur les parties du
monde où les frontières sont contestées
voilà la réalité incontournable qui me
semble-t-il est au coeur du débat
politique de notre méthode schengen 2
c'est ce qui fait la différence
notamment avec madame le pen une
différence de forme
je n'accepterai jamais qu'aucun d'entre
nous vous m'entendez parle de cette
question comme s'il ne s'agissait pas d'
êtres humains jamais de personnes
il s'agit d'êtres humains et ça change
tout il s'agit d'êtres humains ici on va
fille est fidèle à l'identité de la
france on considère que la personne
humaine quelle que soit sa couleur de
peau quel que soit son âge quelle que
soit sa culture
quelle que soit sa religion est sacrée
et donc on ne peut pas parler d'une
question de l'immigration comme on parle
de statistiques
on ne peut pas en parler avec brutalité
avec une humanité et combien de pas me
faire le procès de faiblesse je n'en
n'ai aucune mais je ne veux pas renoncer
à la conviction qui est le coeur de
notre engagement
l'humanisme il ya quoi servirait-il pour
moi d'avoir rappelé si souvent
l'importance de l'identité chrétienne et
des racines chrétiennes de la france si
c'est pour bafouer ses sentiments
lorsqu'il s'agit de parler de femmes
d'enfants qui pourraient être des
membres de nos familles quand claude
quand eric ciotti on parlait justement
de ce qu'ils ont dit y avait aucun
manque de respect à l'endroit de ces
personnes et ça fait toute la différence
ne croyez pas comme madame le pen qu'il
s'agit d'un détail parce que la
différence entre nous et le front
national c'est que nous nous savons que
le détail ça compte et dans vos vies
personnelles comme dans vos vies
professionnelles schengen 2 est
nécessaire parce qu'on ne fera pas face
un continent de 2 milliards 300 millions
d'habitants seule parce que les
problèmes de l'allemagne les problèmes
d'un pays frère comme l'italie ou les
problèmes de l'espagne sont aussi nos
problèmes la question n'est pas se
méfier de nos voisins la question n'est
pas de les tester
la question n'est pas de faire un mur
infranchissable
c'est d'établir ensemble une stratégie
commune et cohérente pour faire face au
même défi qui est au fond le défi du
développement de l'afrique pour que les
jeunes africains trouvent du travail
dans leur continent pour ne pas avoir
espéré qu'il ya du travail chez nous où
nous sommes
merger par chômage par les déficits et
par l'absence de logement s'agissant de
l'accueil des réfugiés
j'ai bien noté les les différentes
formulations j'ai proposé décidément
j'en ai commis d erreur la semaine
dernière à la voix si on y revient
s'était pas autant des erreurs que ça
j'ai proposé l'activation du statut
temporaire de réfugiés de guerre là
encore la personne dont j'ai cité le nom
tout à l'heure a dit c'est pas possible
mon dieu il savait pas que ça existe
depuis 2001 assez préoccupant pour lui
mais encore plus pour ses collaborateurs
il ya personne qui le passe un papier
pour dire ce que propose sarkozy ça fait
14 ans que ça existe peut être con
pourquoi ai-je proposés l'activation du
statut temporaire de réfugiés de guerre
parce que ce n'est pas le même que celui
de réfugié politique face à un afflux si
important de migrants qui fruits
l'horreur notre tradition d'accueil bien
sûr interpellé mais je pense la même
chose pour les chrétiens d'orient
le but ultime de notre engagement c'est
pas que tous les chrétiens d'orient
viennent pas en france c'est que les
chrétiens d'orient puisse vivre heureux
en paix avec leur propre religion en
orient le bun politique c'est tous les
réfugiés syriens puissent revenir en
syrie et non pas que 25 millions de
syriens s'installe en europe pour
laisser un espace vide pour des ch pour
al qaïda et pour tous les autres la
différence me semble t il
minos un réfugié d'air a vocation à être
accueillis sur notre territoire
le temps de la guerre et de revenir
ensuite dans son pays dire cela n'a rien
à voir avec une quelconque forme de
repli sur soi
notre ambition n'est pas que la syrie se
vide de sa population
je propose donc une démarche euro
méditerranéenne qui permettrait la
création à l'extérieur de l'espace de
schengen
deux centres européens dre dans ie tiens
c'est curieux le ministre de l'intérieur
demande ces centres de rétention à
l'extérieur il a dû écouter la
télévision eu aussi je suis heureux de
jouer lé rôle de souffleur vous savez
après tout et pourquoi ces centres de
rétention à l'extérieur parce que mes
chers amis c'est ce que disait
remarquablement et françois noël et
guillaume si quelqu'un prend les risques
pour sa vie et celle de sa famille de
traverser la méditerranée
comment voulez vous qu'ils prennent les
mêmes risques pour revenir il faut donc
instruire les dossiers avant que la
méditerranée ne soient franchies pour
éviter les drames que nous avons connues
or me dit oui mais ces pays pourquoi
accepterait-il ses centres mais
accepterait licence puisque ce sont
devenus des pays de rebond
c'est toute l'afrique subsaharienne qui
rebondit pardon en afrique du nord pour
passer la méditerranée et de dire en
europe
cessant de rétention dans ces pays leur
permettront d'organiser le chaos en
chaos qu'ils connaissent aujourd'hui et
qui créent les drames humains que nous
voyons
naturellement nous finançons riom ces
centres ils seront surveillés par
l'union européenne avec en lien avec le
haut commissariat des nations unies
c'est la seule solution possible pour
faire face au drame que nous connaissons
et puis regardons la france de 2015 elle
est traversée d'immenses tension penser
que l'immigration doit encore augmenter
alors que la communauté nationale est
fragilisée alors que notre marché du
travail
nos finances publiques notre système
éducatif
notre ascenseur social est bloqué penser
qu'on peut continuer comme si de rien
n'était
c'est plaindre le risque d'une
déflagration de la société française
jeudi ces mots parce que je les crois
juste
la situation est beaucoup plus grave
comme l'imaginent les français l'ont
compris
une partie de nos élites la
sous-estiment à dessein cela veut donc
dire que nous devons mettre une
véritable politique de lutte contre les
abus au statut de réfugié politique
c'est quand même invraisemblable que
devant une crise de cette gravité
le président de la république ne soit
pas adressé aux français pour leur dire
voilà on va accueillir provisoirement
les réfugiés de guerre mais parce que
nous allons accueillir des réfugiés de
guerre nous allons lutter contre la
fraude ou statut de réfugié politique et
nous allons arrêter l'immigration
économique
à aucun moment
on attaque l'enam merkel jouer madame
merkel outre les contrôles aux
frontières a dit que la situation créée
sur les fraudes une question essentielle
et donc qu'elle allait donner les moyens
nécessaires pour lutter contre ces
fraudes
je n'accepte pas que les déboutés de
l'asile puisse rester sur le territoire
j'ai vu le projet de madame taubira est
extraordinaire elle dit les demandeurs
d'asile doivent pas être en centre de
rétention
ils doivent être assigné à résidence je
pose une question madame taubira
comment assigné en résidence quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de résidence sur le
territoire français excusez-moi si le
niveau de mon discours est trop élevé
pour par ailleurs je n'accepte pas que
l'insertion des immigrés qui respectent
nos lois
car c'est bien d'eux dont il s'agit soit
dénaturé par ceux qui le méprise car les
premiers scandaleusement montré du doigt
par le mépris de la loi
en témoignent certains étrangers en
situation illégale c'est les étrangers
en situation légale alors le parlement
doit avoir le pouvoir de décider un
plafond non pas un copain un plafond du
nombre d'étrangers non européens admis à
émigrer
chaque année en france et les plafonds
limitatif ainsi défini par la
représentation nationale appliquée par
le gouvernement
cela veut dire quoi qu'un visa de long
séjour pourrait être refusée par un
consulat une carte de séjour pourrait
être refusée par un préfet lorsque le
contingent annuel concernés seraient
dépassés et la demande devrait donc être
examinées
l'année suivante j'irai donc des règles
de conditions d'admission et un plafond
nous devons également reconnaître que
l'immigration est encouragée par la
générosité de notre système social
les français sont fiers d'appartenir à
une nation
inscrit dans la tradition de
l'hospitalité plutôt que dans celle de
la civilité marchande accès montesquieu
qui avait parlé de cela et bien
légitimement nous attendons de ceux qui
désirent s'installer en france qu'ils
aient de bonnes raisons pour cela et que
leur seule raison ne soit pas de
bénéficier d'un système dette sociale
plus généreux qu'ailleurs cela veut donc
dire qu'il ne doit plus être possible
d'accorder des prestations sociales sans
condition de durée de résidence
moi j'étais plutôt sur 50 sur deux ans
et deuxièmement que l'aide médicale
d'état
maintenant il faut la supprimer et le
remplacer chaque l'aude c'est très
simple l'aide médicale d'état ne peut
plus être un système ce doit être une
aide d'urgence
cela veut donc dire sans que ça soit un
système il n'est pas question que sur le
territoire la république française on
laisse mourir quelqu'un au prétexte
qu'elle est étranger ou qui n'a pas de
papiers
on est bien d'accord mais ça c'est un
système
c'est un principe c'est à dire chaque
fois claude qu'il y aurait une urgence
médicale avérée
naturellement les pauses états unis ici
on ne demande pas la carte de crédit
avant de vous opérez ont sauvé la
personne humaine parce que c'est notre
devoir mais y'a pas besoin de prévoir un
système pour cela parce que si vous
prévoyez un système vous avez alors le
détournement du système et la fraude au
système lorsque vous prévoyez simplement
principe sur le territoire de la
république française
on ne laisse pas beau rire quelqu'un qui
est en situation de danger
mais l'icann quelle que soit sa couleur
de peau quelle que soit sa religion
quelles que soient les dates ses papiers
chacun d'entre nous peut parfaitement
comprendre ce que je veux dire et c'est
sans doute ça qui fait aussi la
différence avec madame le pen s'agissant
du droit du sol j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à
cette question
et contrairement à ce que je lis il n'y
a pas de division de notre formation
politique qui est un débat c'est tout à
fait normal et je parlais ce matin des
reit bruno le maire
qui me disait combien on était sur la
même ligne sur toutes ces questions mais
c'est pas des sujets si facile qu'on
trouve la solution tout de suite est la
solution que nous vous proposons entre
ceux qui comme moi gérant riz dont aussi
étions attachés aux principes du droit
du sol
pourquoi parce que mes chers amis
réfléchissez une chose engager le pays
dans des débats idéologiques c'est la
certitude en rien faire et ce qu'ils
voulaient que ça bouge scheer eric il me
semble que nous avons trouvé une
solution qui est tout à fait adapté le
maintien du droit du sol comme
présomption de nationalité si vous êtes
né en france de parents étrangers
vous savez la présomption de nationalité
française mais il ya trois cas où l'état
peut dire non vous ne serez pas français
le premier me semble important si les
parents qui ont eu un enfant sur le
territoire national était en situation
illégale
au moment où est cette enfant il n'y a
pas d'automaticité du droit du sol
deuxièmement sept enfants nés de parents
trajet en france à une présomption de
nationalité chirurgie mais si entre
temps je veux dire jusqu'à ses 16 ans
puisque c'est à partir de saison qui
peut demander la nationalité
il est convaincu d'une activité
terrorisme ou d'un passé de jeunes
délinquants déjà bien accrédités je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi la collectivité
nationale serait obligé de considérer
qu'il s'agit d'un français alors qu'elle
bafoue toutes les valeurs de la
république française
au fond ce n'est pas le droit du sol qui
pose problème c'est le détournement du
droit du sol et c'est le détournement du
droit du sol auxquels nous voulons
mettre un terme
mes chers amis j'aimerais terminer par
là en en demandant l'autorisation propre
équipe de faire un amendement est en
vous entendant je me disais parce que
j'ai essayé de ne pas être parjures à
mes engagements
j'avais dix candidats à la présidence de
notre mouvement que dorénavant
le projet ne serait pas fait en petit
comité de très bons amis qui se mettent
d'accord savez qui coupe la poire en
deux sur tout ce qui fait que la poire
et les couper en 18 et plus personne n'y
comprend rien mais que vous vous auriez
vous prononcer
je vous annonce donc qu'à partir de ce
soir 18h et jusqu'à vendredi 18h vous
allez être appelés à voter sur les
mesures que nous proposons c'est vous
qui allez choisir
nous proposons 11 menu elles seront
présentées par mes amis je me demande
s'il faut pas mettre une douzième pardon
mais bon parce que je trouve que le
débat sur la simulation sur
l'intégration d'un débat central et
c'est une erreur que nous n'ayons pas
mis ma connaissance esprit 6 berbie je
voudrais qu'on interroge nos adhérents
est ce qu'ils attendent d'un étranger
qui demande à devenir français qu'ils
s'assimilent ou juste qu'ils s'intègrent
mai
j'ai des idées sur le sujet et je crois
encore qu'avec henry n'ont pas été loin
de tes premiers en parler c'est un débat
qui n'est pas anecdotique car
l'intégration ça veut dire je viens
comme je suis avec ce que je suis et je
l'intègre ans l'assimilation c'est que
le dernier arrivé accepte la langue
le mode de vie la culture les usages de
ce qu'il rejoint je sais que c'est un
sujet de débat entre nous et bien que
les adhérents donnent leur sentiment
puis je réunirai le bureau politique sur
l'ensemble de ce projet et chaque fois
vous m'entendez bien chaque fois que
nous allons travailler avec eric avec
isabelle que je remercie une nouvelle
fois sur les questions programmatiques
je veillerai à ce que les questions les
plus sensibles soit tranchée par vous
parce qu'au fond contrairement une
partie de nos élites moi je sais une
chose quand on donne la parole au peuple
de france
il est responsable et raisonnable quand
on refuse la parole au peuple de france
alors la colère monte les passions
l'emportent et plus personne ne peut
entendre la raison voilà ce que je pense
mais cher thierry pas simplement sur
l'immigration sur tous les sujets et
avec toute l'équipe qui m'entoure et
notamment christian c'est comme cela que
nous allons conduire les choses je vous
demande donc des très nombreux à
participer à cette consultation
parce que plus vous serez nombreux plus
cela donnera de la force et voyez vous
voilà les républicains
nous ne nous laisserons pas imposer la
nouvelle pensée unique nous n'irons pas
plus loin
quelles que soient les passions
françaises que nos convictions ne
l'autorisent et nous le permettent nous
refuserons tous les amalgames tout
risque qu'en face il est entre le mur de
la fermeture et de l'inhumanité d'un
côté et lèvres
rayon fossé de démission et de lâcheté
de l'autre côté la place des
républicains est immense c'est la place
des hommes et des femmes qui veulent
être à la hauteur de l'histoire de la
france l histoire la france elle est
faite pour l'altitude
elle n'est pas faite pour la princesse
de le remercier